hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
we are back this morning with some new
videos for you guys what we have right
here are two
macbook airs they're both 2020 models
they're both 999 they both have eight
gigs of ram
except this one has an intel chip and
this one has
apple's brand new insane m1
chip now what we're going to do in this
video is compare
everything all of the new changes all
the differences we're going to be
looking at
the thermals the temperatures using this
little
seek thermal camera attachment is
actually really cool i'll show you guys
in just a second
we're going to be playing some games
we're going to do some ipad
games with controller support we're
going to test that out we're also going
to play some x86 games
under rosetta and of course we're going
to be testing out some
benchmarks and some other real world
tests to see
how big of a difference there is between
these two because this is the most
fair comparison you can make they're
both the base model macbook airs
for 999 dollars and the last thing we're
going to test
is battery life as you can see both of
these are plugged in
now what we're going to do is we're
going to unplug them we're going to run
all the tests
throughout this entire video however
long it takes to shoot this
and at the end we're going to check the
battery life on both of these
to see how big of a difference there is
the first thing we're going to do is get
an initial thermal reading
we have the seek thermal app right here
open and as you guys can see
on the intel side we're at 33 degrees
celsius these are both plugged in and
they are idle let's go over to the m1
looks like we have 28
degrees celsius at idle and it looks to
me
like the heat point is actually smaller
over here
closer to the corner so that is a huge
difference
five degrees celsius while idling
so both of these are fully charged i'm
going to go ahead and
unplug them now talking about the
physical differences
there really isn't much at all they're
basically the same the battery sizes are
the same
the body sizes thickness everything
displays
the only significant difference is the
new p3 wide color gamut support with the
m1 macbook air as you can see
we can view this webkit logo whereas on
the old
intel mac you cannot so that's actually
a pretty big deal for people who
needed a macbook for color grading or
photo editing that's actually
a pretty big deal so for people who
require that you can actually go with a
macbook air this year
now as far as the keyboards and track
pads track pads are identical
and the keyboards with the magic key
feel is the same
however there are some new keys or
buttons
as you guys can see right here we have a
little globe logo
if you tap it we get the emojis
so you don't need the touch bar to get
this this is actually a really nice
touch because it blends in better with
the
kind of ios ecosystem on top of that
we're replacing three keys right here
the function row
instead of these three with the keyboard
backlighting controls
and this app key we are now getting a
spotlight search key which is very
useful
we're also getting a dictation key and
do not disturb which is a pretty
interesting addition
because it's mainly used to not get
notifications and it's very useful for
lte so i'm wondering if we'll be getting
lte service for macbooks sometime later
now one of the things a lot of people
are complaining about is the lack of
four ports
but the old intel macbook air from this
year
still just has two thunderbolt 3 ports
whereas the new m1 macbook air has two
usb
4 ports which also support thunderbolt 3
as well
so on the newer macbooks that we might
be seeing next year we should be getting
four ports
now let's go ahead and jump into
performance which is the main
focus of this video we've got geekbench
5 right here as you can see the intel
has the i3
running at 1.1 gigahertz and we have the
new apple m1 right here with 3.19
gigahertz
both have eight gigs of ram and we're
going to be testing that
a little bit later to see if eight gigs
really is enough
for the new m1 chip with the new unified
architecture so let's go ahead and
run the cpu benchmark geekbench is
finishing up and as you guys can see
we're at 29 degrees
celsius on the m1 moving over to the
intel we're at 36 degrees celsius so
it's quite
a bit hotter that's seven degree
difference
in celsius all right guys those of you
who bought the intel
version of the macbook air earlier this
year i am so sorry
we have our results all right the
multi-core score
is about three and a half times
faster the same 999 dollars
three and a half times faster and for
single core
you're getting about 65 faster
performance as well
this score is absolutely insane it's
mind-blowing now if you guys want to see
how this new m1
fanless macbook air compares to the
macbook pro
with the fan make sure to subscribe
right now because we're getting that
video out soon
and we're really trying to hit 500k subs
by the end of the year so
thank you guys now moving on to the
graphics test this is gonna show a huge
difference
let's go ahead and just run it all right
we have our scores and as you guys know
this has the seven
core gpu not the eight core m1 but here
we're getting 2.7
times faster graphics performance and
even if you get the best i7 model with
the g7 graphics
that gets around 10 000 metal scores so
this is still
almost two times faster even with that
now before we get into a real world
gaming comparison test i do want to
compare
the webcams and the microphones because
apple did say that it has a new isp
image signal processor inside of the m1
so let's go ahead and test that out this
is the webcam and the microphone on the
intel
macbook air and what i'm saying right
now is a lot of noise in the exposures
kind of dark my hair is kind of crushed
definitely does not look good
now moving over to the m1 macbook air
i'm actually pleasantly surprised
because the whole scene
is better exposed everything looks
brighter and my hair is no longer
crushed but i
am seeing some noise so the 720p
webcam still isn't great but it's
definitely improved
moving on i have cinebench r23 open
right here and we're just going to go
ahead and
start the test this is going to be a 10
minute test
and we're going to start hearing the fan
kick up on the intel macbook air
which we won't on this new one you guys
can already see
after about 40 seconds this thing is so
far ahead it's insane this thing's
chugging behind we actually have our
temps right here tg fan pro it says it's
at 100 degrees celsius
the chip is at 100 degrees unfortunately
it doesn't work on the m1 macbook air
because the sensors
aren't quite supported yet but they're
both maxed out at 100
cpu so the m1 is basically finishing up
right now with the
first score this one's like halfway
it's kind of funny seeing this and i am
hearing
the fan starting to kick up a little bit
on the intel
let's see we've got 56 of the fans
capacity
is happening on the intel which is kind
of crazy
this is completely fanless you don't
have to worry about that at all now it's
going up to
61 and it's very interesting that it's
been at 100 degrees
the whole time and it's only now
starting to kick up it actually took
quite a bit a couple of minutes
all right we're about seven minutes into
the test and
we're at 100 fan speed on the intel
you guys can probably hear that now
looking at the thermals the intel
macbook air looks to be at 40 degrees
celsius actually 41 right there and
looking at the m1
we are at 39 degrees 40. so
they're actually very similar but it's
impressive because there's absolutely no
fan at all
on the m1 and it's still one to two
degrees
cooler celsius all right just because
i'm curious i opened up intel power
gadget and it looks like the
intel macbook air has taken about 10 10
and a half
watts of power in full load
while it's throttling now in our last
video benchmarking the macbook air we
actually found some very interesting
results we found that
it does in fact throttle so definitely
watch that video
if you're curious to find out about that
but we found out that
the new m1 macbook air after it
throttles it takes about seven
watts of power so even when you're doing
a full
workload throttling the m1 is gonna be
taking
less battery life as well all right we
just got a result and this is
hilarious 66 25 points on the m1
16 63 points on the intel
now that gap is increased so in
geekbench
5 it was around 3.5 times faster
now it's four times faster so that shows
the difference in thermal throttling
which is hilarious because this has no
fan at all completely silent compared to
a fan powered intel macbook air this is
just
it's crazy now i know not everyone's
going to put that heavy of workload on
the macbook air of course you can now
with the m1 macbook but
in the real world what does being
fanless
truly mean with the intel macbook air a
lot of people complained about zoom so
we have it open right here
so far everything's going well but we're
gonna see after a little bit of time
does it heat up and does the fan kick up
so far it's been a couple of minutes and
the intel model is heating up already to
around
70 degrees celsius now the quad core
models they heat up a lot more this is
the dual core i3
so this one is a little bit better in
terms of thermals and fan noise
alright so it's been about 15 minutes
using zoom exclusively on both of these
and so far the dual core
i3 macbook air is fine the fans aren't
kicking up yet
so it seems like when it's by itself
it's totally fine but when you start
multitasking
we did notice that it started to use a
little bit more power and started
heating up a little bit more
but one thing that's very interesting is
that right now the cpu on the intel
macbook has taken about five
watts of power the entire cpu whereas
over
on the m1 macbook air the entire package
including the ram and everything in that
m1 ship
is taking 1.3
watts so 1.3 watts compared to 5
but if we just look at the cpu by itself
0.565
watts with the m1 is all it's taking
compared to around 5 watts on the intel
so this is actually going to have a
significant
impact on long-term battery life when
doing stuff like this zoom calls
at this point the quad-core models would
already be running loud the fans would
be kicked up and that's why
we recommended the dual core i3s because
it's a lot better for
thermals now in reality most people will
also have something else open maybe a
couple of
different apps multitasking typing so
what we did is we
opened up google chrome now of course we
don't have the updated apple silicon
version because
that got taken down so we have the
original chrome version
it is running under rosetta so it's not
optimized for it the cpu on the intel is
showing 100 degrees
celsius so just running zoom and one
video
it's maxed out so this right here is a
1080p
60 video running on both and i don't
know if you guys can notice
but the m1 is playing it back
perfectly fps whereas on the
intel we're dropping a lot of frames
here
the cpu on the i3 is at 100 degrees
celsius i can hear the fans they're very
loud and we are having
issues where this keeps buffering it's
not very responsive and it's dropping
frames like crazy whereas the m1
perfectly smooth
60fps no issues it's interesting that
the cpu on the m1 is only at around 36
to 42 percent usage and the gpu is at 44
whereas on the intel we're at 83
cpu usage now it's 95 with 25
on the gpu so it's really cranking up
trying to run this video whereas the m1
is doing it
perfectly fine using rosetta emulation
which is extremely impressive so
if you are running a couple of other
things in the background or something
like a youtube video
along with zoom you are gonna get
loud fan noise even on the dual core
now because the m1 is running chrome so
well under rosetta
i'm curious to see the actual web
browsing performance so i have
speedometer 2.0 open right here
i'm gonna go ahead and run it all right
wow now this i was not
expecting because even though we're
under rosetta
114 runs per minute compared to 95.9
this is optimized for x86 this is not
so let's go ahead and jump into safari
which is optimized for
both of these and run it again now
what's very interesting about this
test is that right now the cpu on the m1
is about 20
usage whereas on the intel we're sitting
at around 37 to 45
usage so it's using basically twice as
much power
to run this test the intel macbook air
just finished with a score of 96.7
that's very similar to chrome whereas on
the m1 we got a score of 225 points
that's around 2.2 times faster
for web browsing performance which
everybody does on the macbook air
now one of the claims that apple made
was that the ssds on the new m1 macbooks
are twice as fast at least on the
macbook air
so let's go ahead and compare that these
are both 256
gig models so let's run blackmagic's
disk speed test we have our scores and
apple
was not kidding we went from 812
megabytes per second right on the intel
to
2200 that is 2.7 times
faster for write speeds on the ssd
and for the read we went from 1300 to
2600 so that is
double the speed for the read this is
basically gonna help the entire system
feel more snappy apps are going to open
quicker
and transferring files from thunderbolt
3 drives is going to be faster as well
now with that out of the way let's get
into
gaming now previously no one would ever
buy a macbook air for gaming but now
with the m1 it actually does make sense
especially if you guys watched our
video from yesterday extremely
impressive but what we're going to do is
we're going to run a game
under rosetta an x86 game for the mac
then we're going to get into
iphone and ipad gaming with controller
support that's going to be very
interesting but first
i do want to run a benchmark this is gfx
bench
metal and it is optimized for apple
silicon
i'm gonna run the 1440p aztec ruins high
tier off screen test
now this score is what i am talking
about
if you guys remember we ran the metal
test in geekbench the m1 was 2.7 times
faster in that benchmark but for gaming
we are getting 4.16 times
faster with the m1 and even bigger gap
for gaming we have league of legends
open right here it's actually finishing
up downloading on the intel version
this is going to be running using
rosetta 2
on the m1 macbook air so keep that in
mind
but while it's downloading i'm going to
go ahead and show you guys
the ios game support here i am in the
app store and i just searched up
call of duty because i'm trying to play
call of duty mobile but unfortunately
it's not there i don't know if you guys
can see but right here on the m1 macbook
we have an additional option
to choose ipad and iphone apps
and call of duty mobile does not show up
so
i'm sorry for all the people i hyped up
because on day one we are not getting
all the games that we want to play now i
actually did a little bit of research
and it seems like
there are some games that did not
automatically get put on the mac
app store and i feel like it could be
because of controller support because
i looked up a lot of controller games
and those games would not show up but i
was able to download a couple of games
just to show you guys how it's going to
be like
of course apps are going to be the same
way so here we have eternium
it's an rpg now for an ipad game like
this it should be supporting full screen
but it seems like there's a bug where
the full screen button is not working so
we're getting this smaller window
but the cool thing about what apple is
doing is they're doing automatic
translation
so when you click on the trackpad and
when you swipe it gets translated to a
touch
on an ipad so i'll show you guys here we
are we're playing
every tap that i do gets registered so
i'm able to play just like you would
on an ipad another cool thing is that it
did say that it logged into game center
but here i am check this out i'm just
clicking and i'm playing just like that
i'm able to move around now watch this
it supports swipe support so
this game actually has swipe gestures
so this is a pretty fun free rpg
and as you can see it's working pretty
well
i'm getting no drop frames no issues at
all playing a game like this
now i'm gonna go ahead and close this
and show you guys the other game that i
downloaded
this one is dark raider it's also free
and it does have
controller support as you guys can see
we have game center showing up right
here so the nice thing is that when you
play on your mac
it's going to sync up to your results or
your
progress on your iphone or your ipad so
let's get right into it this is the xbox
wireless controller i'm gonna just put
it into pairing mode
all right we're in pairing mode and it
pops up right here xbox wireless
controller just like that
click connect and there we go the
controller is connected
and already it's working perfectly
just like that so let's continue as you
guys can see controller support is
working on this game
and basically this shows that it's going
to work
the same way on other games now i do
expect games like call of duty mobile
and the better games to come out very
soon
with controller support because i am so
excited to play that
and we should be seeing full screen
support coming soon as well i think it's
just a bug that we're getting
no drop frames no stuttering i mean this
is great
now of course it's not just the games
apple actually has a new category right
here with a bunch of new different apps
like hbo max
other stuff like that that came from the
iphone and the ipad
look at that e-trade investing that
stuff is going to be showing up on these
macs and i think
over time it's gonna get much better as
more developers realize that they can
code for both of these at the same time
there's gonna be better support there's
gonna be much better games showing up
with controller support all that kind of
stuff
and hopefully keyboard and mouse gaming
support coming soon because apple
did talk about that at their wwdc so if
an ipad gets keyboard and mouse supports
the macbook is gonna get it too now
we're back in league of legends we have
the practice tool opened
right here so we're gonna go ahead and
join with those matches because you guys
kind of made fun of us in the last one
for dying in an actual match so let's
get into it
here we are in the graphics settings
they're both set to the default which is
1440
by 900 resolution the custom slider
is to increase quality on both and they
both have everything on medium
and anti-aliasing is enabled as well so
let's
load these graphic settings now when
we're just standing there and idling
the intel macbook air was getting around
80 fps compared to 120 fps
on the m1 right now that we're getting
into some action i've got
60 fps on the intel i've got 107
fps on the m110
so 60 to 67 fps compared to oh look at
that 130 i just hit
on the m1 so when you're in action
there's an even bigger gap 138 what i'm
gonna do now is go back
into our graphics settings and i'm gonna
max everything out
to see how they both handle it 2560 by
1600
on the resolution very high on all of
these settings just completely
max them out i'm hitting 75 fps right
now on the m1
compared to 30 and 37 on the intel so
basically what we're seeing is
when we're maxing out the graphics we're
getting two times
better gaming performance on the m1 but
do not forget
this is an x86 optimized mac
game and it's running under rosetta
it is not optimized for apple silicon
and to think that we're getting
performance like this
for the same price a thousand dollars is
just
mind-blowing and you don't even have to
wait
for apps and games to be optimized for
apple silicon this is just incredible
i'm definitely hearing the fans on the
old macbook air
of course the m1 is fanless now i got my
thermal camera right here
looking like 49 degrees celsius on the
intel
that's hot 36
degrees celsius on the m1
13 degree difference
and this one has a fan now let's go
ahead and get into the logic pro
music production testing i have the new
logic benchmark open up here
i've adjusted the settings to use the
maximum amount of processing threads
eight here and four there i've messed
with all the settings now you might see
that we have
250 tracks loaded up that's because we
were testing on the imax
previously but let's see how many tracks
each one of these can handle now i do
want to mention
before we begin this test that we are
going to be testing this with
the m1 macbook pro that does have a fan
and it
is able to hit higher frequencies so if
you want to see that definitely
subscribe
right now i have 20 tracks loaded up and
let's go ahead and hit play
and if it's not going to work it should
crash yep
the intel just crashed and the m1 is
still chugging along
perfectly fine cpu usage is 34
really on the m1 try it again on the
intel what's the cpu usage there 100
let's see
it spikes up it hit 50 and it just
crashed but this one's still going
still going strong now because the intel
macbook air crashed i'm gonna try to run
10
we'll see if it can run 10 tracks oh i
just saw it skip
but it's still going it's still going
let's see if it runs the
full i think 30 seconds it almost
finished the full test but it did
overload at the end which means it did
fail the test it was not able to do 10
tracks
so obviously the m1 can do more than
double
the tracks but i brought the intel down
to 8 and the m1 to 30 and let's run it
again
wow guys i can't believe that this is
handling 30 so well the cpu usage
is at 38 running 30 tracks this one is
at
60 percent running eight tracks
the intel macbook air handled eight so
i'm going to turn on one more
nine and let's go up to 50 tracks
on the m1 the m1 is handling 50 with
ease
the cpu is still at 51 usage
it's not skipping a beat even though
it's fanless
we're not getting any throttling it's
not getting hot
oh the intel just overloaded it cannot
do
nine tracks it can only handle eight
tracks while this is
killing 50. now we're going straight for
a hundred on the m1
this could be nope it overloaded okay
we're gonna go down a little bit
here's 95 tracks and so far it's almost
all the way through and it's perfectly
fine
83 cpu usage right now oh
right at the end it just overloaded
right as it was about to get done
so i think 95 is still too much maybe
94.93
that is insane because we tested the
2020 imac
the 27 inch model with the 8 core
processor
that's 2300 and that was able to handle
125 tracks
that's a desktop mac so if you're a
logic pro user
before the macbook air was a no-go
eight-tracks
compared to 93-94 tracks that is just
such a massive difference that you can
actually
buy the macbook air and get really good
logic performance
all right guys now with all of that
testing out of the way
it's been just about three and a half
hours since we unplugged these
macbooks check this out the intel
macbook is at eight
percent battery life and the m1 is at
37 battery life now keep in mind guys
the displays were maxed out the entire
time i turned off auto brightness
i turned off display dimming on the
battery and on top of that we were
putting a
really heavy workload the entire time on
both of these now you might be wondering
how is this possible how is there such a
massive difference
seven percent to 37 the reason is
even when we're using the full
performance of the m1 macbook air
it's still using less wattage than the
intel
and one more thing quite a few of the
apps that we were running
on the m1 macbook air were not optimized
for apple silicon
just yet so when everything gets
optimized
it's going to be even better than it is
right now
now let's finally answer the final
question should you upgrade to the
m1 macbook air well i'd say that
even if you have the new 2020 intel
model
you should upgrade and i'm sorry guys
but
if you have one of these try to sell it
asap
before everybody else catches on to the
m1 because it's just such a massive
difference
it destroyed it in every single
benchmark every test
everything it destroyed it even using
rosetta
to emulate x86 compared to native x86
kills it in every way including the
battery life there is just
no competition and i'd say this macbook
air is so impressive
that some people who are looking at the
macbook pro with the m1
might just want to buy this one because
it's performing so well and it's not
throttling
like we thought it would now we are
going to be doing a video
directly comparing the m1 macbook air
to the m1 macbook pro to see how big of
a difference there is
thanks to that fan and the last thing i
want to mention is that if you
see a discounted intel macbook air maybe
even as low as
seven eight hundred dollars do not buy
it
never buy an intel macbook ever again
only apple silicon because the
difference is just that huge
so there you guys go thanks for sticking
out to the end of this video
let us know your thoughts and comments
down below
please click that circle above to
subscribe help us reach our goal of 500k
guys thanks for watching check out one
of those two videos right there
especially the benchmark video
and we will see you in the next one